お願いします まあ今日のテーマは敗者を作らずに勝者と読むんですかね
まあ勝者になること可能ですかっていう
まあそういうテーマで
お釈迦様おっしゃっているあの仏教的な生き方
どういう生き方でしょうかと
あるいは違う言葉で言えば
お釈迦様が我々にどんな
どんなような人間になればよろしいかと教えた方法なんですね
タイトルはそのようになりましたけど
一応内容はあの まあお釈迦様がどのような人間になればよろしいかと我々に教えたかというテーマにはなります
で お釈迦様がこういう言葉が教えたことがあります
パーリ語なんですけど
これは法句経というテキストの 201番
それは読み方はジャヤン・ヴェーラン・パサヴァティ・ドゥッカム・セーティ・パラジャヨ・ウパサントー・スッカム・セーティ・ヒットワー・ジャヤ・パラジャヤン
この前もいくつかの講演会で同じ偈を紹介いたしましたと思いますけど
ジャヤンというのは勝利者ですね
勝者ですね 勝った人がヴェーラン・パサヴァティ
敵を作りますと ヴェーランというのは怒りですね
だから他人の心にパサヴァティっていうのはものすごくこのもう煮出すというふうな意味で
まあ大きくするということで
相手の心にすごい怒りを作る
いわゆる勝った人が敵を作るという意味なんです
そこでドゥッカム・セーティ・パラジャヨ
2行目 パラジャヨ 負けた人がドゥッカム
すごく苦しくて生活苦しくなることになるんだ
いわゆる悔しくなってしまうんだということ
負けたら悔しい 勝ったら敵を作るということ
そこで 3行目 ウパサントー
まあ心を安定した人 心を育てた人がスッカム・セーティ
すごく楽に生きているんだと
安心してスッカというのは楽
ドゥッカっていうのは苦しみという言葉ですからね
その場でその場で翻訳はちょっとちょっと変わりますけど
心を育てた人が心を安心した人が楽しく楽に正気生活するんだと
どのように生活するかというと
ヒットワー ジャヤ パラジャヤ
ジャヤっていうのは勝つこと
パラジャヤっていうのは負けること
ヒットワーっていうのは置いておいて
そんなことは気にしないで
それを置いておいて いわゆる乗り越えて
勝つか負けるかという
そのことを乗り越えて
大変楽に生活するんだと
そういうことで お釈迦様が我々に教えたのは
この この勝ち負けの人生ではなくて
それを乗り越えた何か生き方があるんではないかなということなんです
まあいろいろきめ細かいポイントをたくさん言うかもしれませんだけど
それほど順番がございませんので
適当に申し上げます で
なぜ仏教を始めたかということもね
皆様よくご存知のストーリーがございまして
お釈迦様がこの人間がなんで苦しみのかという問題に大変ぶつかってしまって
どのように頑張っても人間苦しむことだけ結果ではないかと
何かここを脱出する方法はないかという
この問題に問題を解決しようと思って出家して修行に励みましたし
いろいろ方法も試してみました
それでお釈迦様はその方法を見つかるんですね
苦しみを乗り越える方法
見つかったところで大変喜んで
やっと見つかりましたと
この平安な道 心の平安になること
心が平安になること やっと見つかりましたと
そこでせっかく自分がその道を見つかったんだけど
この方法を考えたところで
これあまりにも人間には理解しにくいんですよ
これは人間には理解しにくいんだと
それで私は一生懸命みんなにもこの幸せになる道を教えようとしたら
みんな理解しないで理解にあまりにも苦しんでかなり苦労するだろうと
ですから 人に迷惑をかけてはならんと
余計なおせっかいになるんだと
わかるもわかることもできないものを教えようとしちゃうと
これはすごい迷惑なんですね
じゃあまあいいですよと
私だけで 言わないことにしますよという話がありまして
そこで梵天の神が降りてきて
そんなことをしたら大変だと
人間にはこの真理の道がわからないんだと
教えてあげなかったら大変なことになるんだと
ですから なんとか頑張って教えてくださいと
みんなバカではないんだと
わかる人もいるんだと
だからわかる人でもわかってくれないと大変損ではないかというふうにお願いしたところで
お釈迦様がじゃあわかりましたと
自分でも考えたら 人間みんな同じじゃなくて
物事を理解できる人もいるんだと
理解できる人には苦労してでも教えた方がいいんではないかなと思って
じゃあこれから教えますよと
法門を開けますよと 安心しなさいよと
確信しなさいよと みんなに迷惑かけるんだ
かけるということ かけるのだから
私は教える気持ちには初めはなかったとというふうにお釈迦様は教えるんですね
その一言葉でも見えるのは
お釈迦様はやっぱりみんなに
すべての生命に対してすごく優しかったんですね
だから生命に対して優しさっていうのは必要ですよと
その気持ちは最初からもあったんです
それは仏教でいうこの慈しみの気持ちなんですね
だから生きているものが本当に他人から優しくしてほしいんですよ
それは基本的なんです
優しくするなよというふうに言う人がいません
で それはまあ基本的な心理なんですけど
それさえも人が分かろうとしないんですね
それさえも忘れているんです
ちょっと考えればわかることなんですよ
生きるものはみんな優しくしてほしがってるんだと
だって人間はいろいろ動物飼ってるでしょうに
どんな動物でも飼って親切に優しくすると
結構人間言うことを聞く
人間のことも心配するようになる
何もできませんだけど
動物たちには それでも心配します
人間も飼っている馬とか牛とかね
まあ日本では牛は仕事にさせませんだけどね
まあインドとかね まあまあそういう国々では
自分の国にも牛も仕事をするんですよ
水牛もいてね 水牛もよく仕事をするんです
仕事をしなきゃいいでしょうに
別に牛が人間飼わなくても自分たちで生活できるでしょうし
それでも人間に捕まれて
人間が親切にいろいろ体を洗ってあげたり
面倒を見てあげたり 優しい言葉をかけたりすると
やっぱり人間言うことを聞いて
人間の仕事を助けてくれるんですね
馬でも全然人間の手がなくたっても何のことなく生活できます
でも動物さえ親切にしてあげれば
もう相手のことを心配するんですよ
それさえも人間だけ忘れているんですね
ですから この 幸せに生きたければ
楽しく楽に幸せに生きたければ
人間に一番最初に必要なのは
すべての生命に対してこの慈しみの気持ちなんです
それは全然 1円もかからないんですよ
ただ心変えるだけなんです
どんな人に対しても どんな生き物に対しても
いかなる生き物に対しても優しさ
それ育てればそこにすごい幸せな生き方が成り立つんです
互いに心配して 互いに面倒を見る
互いの幸せを願う 生命システムが成り立つんです
それはまあ 生命の本能みたいなものなんですよ
だからもう早々接する安らぎと楽しみが生まれてくるんです
生きることは何のことなく大変楽しいことになるんです
すごくうまく 例えば川が下へ下へ
何の苦労もなし 流れていくような感じで
人生っていうのは流れるんです
そこは仏教で最初から教えてる一つのポイントなんです
そこでなんでこの人間だけ他人に対して
優しくないんですかと
そのポイントからもう人間の頭が悪いという立場がお釈迦様は取っているんですよ
頭が悪いんだと 物事を考えないんだと
だから結局この質問に可能かという質問に答えはただそれだけなんですよ
敗者にならないようなね
生き方が可能ですか？と
一切の生命に対して当たり前のことである優しさが自分の心に育てれば
それだけで可能なんです
じゃあそれ大変なことですかね
いとも簡単でしょう それほど簡単なことがないんです
慈しみということ それは生命の本能なんです
人々に対して優しく親切にする
これ 人々と言ったっても
仏教では人々と言わない
衆生と言うんですね 全ての生命
まあ生命に対して優しくする
それで なんでそれは本能かというと
私たちはなぜ大人として育てられたんですかと
それは周りの人々の優しさがあったんだからでしょう
もし生まれた時から誰も親切にしてくれなかったならば
こんなに大人になれることはできないんです
精神的にも肉体的にも健康な体を作って
立派な大人になることはできなかったはずなんです
そこで子供たちはいろいろトラブルを起こしたり
精神的に混乱したりするでしょう
何が欠けているかというと
親切さ 他人から子供たちに与えるべき親切さが欠けているんです
で 昨日ですかね ニュースで流れたんだけど
中学生の一年生が 二年生を殺したか 二年生が一年生を殺したかよくはっきりしませんだけど
私の場合 これ中学生でしょうに
我々から見ればもうもう子供でしょ
人殺しやっちゃう なんでみんな仲良くふざけて遊んで
もう喧嘩しながらもう学校の勉強できないんですかね
普通だったらそうでしょう
子供っていうのは喧嘩はするし
ものすごく騒いだりもするし
もう学校の窓も破ったりもするし
まあそれでも別にどうったことはないんですよ
あまりにもあっちこち走り回ったりすると
知らないうちに学校の窓ガラスも破れたりする
いい加減にしないさいかといえば
それだけのことです なんでそういうふうに気楽に楽しく生きていられないんですかね
その子供二人もやっぱりお互いに敵同士やと
人間見るとなんかすごい敵だと
我々はなんか山の中で突然熊に出会ったような感じでしょ
山歩きしたところで熊に出会ったらどうしますかね
逃げるか熊を倒すかどっちかになるでしょうに
だから子供たちにも教えられてないか
子供たちに十分この優しさのことを教えられてないかということなんですね
それでああいうふうに不幸になってしまうんですね
二人とも不幸でしょ 殺した側も殺された側も
それで皆様方はまあ私と違って子供を育てた経験あるでしょうに
赤ちゃんが生まれたその瞬間からもうすごくこの愛情というのを欲しがってるんです
その愛情は十分与えてあげると
何のことなくすっごくすくすくと育ててしまうんですね
大きくなっていくんですよ
その愛情は綺麗に与えてもらうと
決して親を恨むことというのはしないんです
他の人も恨むことはしない
そんなことわからなくなっちゃうんです
なぜ恨むべきかと で 人間っていうのはそういうふうにいろんなところで失敗するんです
この失敗はお釈迦様は認めないんです
あまりにも頭が悪いんじゃないんですかと
ちょっと目を開けて世の中を見なさいよと
生命がいつでも必要としているのは優しさではないかと
殺してくれと頼む動物も一匹もいませんよ
だから そういうとても当たり前の単純なことを忘れる
その単純なことを一番基本的なこと
必要なことを忘れたところで
人間が勝手に巨大な苦しみを作っているんです
[背景音楽]そこは大体今日のテーマになる疑問がこの競争の競争心理なんですね
で 現代人がすごく威張って
我々の世界は競争世界だと
我々の経済は競争的な経済ですよと
教育も競争ですよと 商売なんかは競争しなきゃ成り立たないんだと
で 世の中で競争すること
戦うことは正しいと それで豊かになっているんだというふうに思っています
私が言いたいのは それ勘違いですよと
頭あまりにも悪いんだから
そういうふうなことを考えているんだと
この競争的な経済学は
お釈迦様が作った経済学ではありません
それはこの初めからの怒りと嫉妬と憎しみで
物事を考える人々が作った考え方なんです
仏教以外 他の宗教の聖書という
あのガラクタの本なんか読んでみてください
そこで怒り 憎しみ もう絡み合ってるんです
私は絶対的な神ですよと
私以外何かを拝むことは絶対許せませんと
嫉妬の神ですよと そこからも
もう人間に嫉妬すること
競争すること 相手を倒すこと
憎むことを教えているんです
その中でまた相手をもう人間に対して親切にしてくださいとまた言うんです
だから論理はっきりしないんです
そこでこの偶像崇拝という言葉が出ていて
この ですごく自分たちが文化人で
で 神を信じるんであって
神には形はないんだと
人間に神の形作ることはできませんと
だから他の野蛮人たちが偶像崇拝するんだと
いろんな形 形の神を作ったりしてとか
そこでそれを壊してやろうと
で 壊したりするでしょう
他人の宗教なんかは そちらに何があるんですかと
怒りでしょうに 憎しみでしょうに
そういう世界から生まれてきた経済学を
世界中全ての人類を学んで勉強して勝手に苦しんでるだけなんです
そこでそれはなぜ悪いかというと
じゃあ経済学的に考えましょう
我々は商売でもよろしいし
何か産業でも何でもいい
それは競争だと 競争っていうのは誰かを倒すことなんです
でも自分が作る品物が人が買ってもらわなくてはならないでしょう
だから ある面で経済を成り立たすために
経済が動くためには 人々が幸せにいなくちゃいけないんですよ
作った品物を買うために購買力なければ買えないでしょうに
それなのにその相手に対して競争する
攻撃をかける それで品物を買った人は損する
負ける 損したら 負けたらどうなりますかというと
マーケットがなくなる
マーケットがどんどん小さくなる
こちらはどんどん品物を作る
作れば作るほどマーケットが死んでしまうんです
それで結果どうなりますか？売れなくなるでしょう
お互いに死ぬということになるんです
その現象は世界中 この自由経済の世界で明確にあるでしょうに
だからみんな自分の命まで健康までかけて商売やってるんです
で うまくいかないんです
マーケットのことを無視して
同じ品物はいろんなところで作ったりする
品物であろうがサービスであろうが何でもいいんです
だから基本的におかしいんじゃないですかね
はい で認めない おかしいということは
そこは私はおかしいと思いますよ
いろんなところでいろんなサービスやら品物やら作って売ろう売ろうとしてるんだけど
売れないんだ 売れないんだと泣いてるでしょうに
プロフィットがないんだと泣いてるでしょうに
はい だからそれはおかしいとそれでも気がつかないんです
とにかくそこで会社は何言いますかというと
もっと攻撃的に商売しなさいと
もっと嘘嘘をばらまきなさいと
嘘の宣伝もしなさいと
もう何でもやるんです
品物にはない もう性能なんか全部説明するんですね
だからこの間笑ったのは
この映画の宣伝 電車で見て
いつでもせんべいヒットナンバーワン
嘘でしょうに だからいっぺんに大体アメリカから
例えば映画３本  4本上映しているでしょうに
全てヒットナンバーワンなんです
どうやってヒットナンバーワンになるんだよ
全部 そこで最高傑作 何々さんの
この最高傑作という映画見たってもすごいつまらないんですよ
だから最高傑作だからそれ人しかないでしょう
傑作っていうのは辞書を引いてみると
この人への傑作は次から次へ出るんですよ
だから言葉もいい加減に使って嘘ばっかりばらまいて
なんでそうするんですかというと
売るためなんですね なんでそんな嘘まで言って売りますかというと
いらないものを作っているんだからなんです
あるいは買うお金が消費者にないんだからなんです
嘘でも言って騙さなくてはならないと
そういう恐ろしい経済システムができちゃったんだから
同じ考え方で教育も恐ろしい競争になってるんだから
人間っていうのは生きる喜びを感じなくなっちゃうんです
生きることは大変苦しくなるんです
そこで競争のウイルスが心に入っちゃったんだから
何でも競争になる 服を着ることも競争
お化粧することも競争
建物を造ることも競争
買う 家のために買う 何でしたっけ？あれは家具とかね
それも誰かさんとの競争
言って 人間の思考っていうのはどうすれば苦しみますかということをしか考えてないんです
苦しまなきゃ気が済まないんです
そんなにも苦しめたければいい
勝手にいいんだけど また文句言うんですね
苦しいんだから なんとかならないかと
何にもなりません 自分が苦しみたいんだから苦しんでるだけであって
だから苦しみたくなければ
もうちょっと明確に物事を考えないと
で いろいろ個人的な人々の問題とかを聞く時でも
よくわかることは やっぱり楽しくなる方法を教えるんだけど
それをわかりますとわかりますと言うんだけど
実行はしません 実行しないで
また苦しんで苦しんで行き詰まったところでまた私に電話かけてくるんです
で 私はまた同じことを言わなくちゃいけないんですね
一旦私はちょっときつく物事を言うんだから
まあ言われた時はそのショックでいくらかは落ち着きますけど
また2  3週間でまた同じパターンで
ある日ある人にこう言ったんですよ
そのあなたのその思考やら考え方っていうのは
その それは良くないんだと自分でも知ってるでしょうにと
それ自分が苦しいっていうことも知ってるでしょうにと
それでも自分が勝手にやってるんだからね
勝手にしたらどうですかと
楽しくなろうと思えばご自分の力でできるし
でもそうしないで また変な考え方で苦しんでるんだと
何回何回も言われてるんだから
方法を知ってるでしょと
だから知っていても苦しみの方向へ心が行ってしまうんですね
だからこの競争という言葉が
戦うという言葉自体が
人間は物事を理解してないんだから
理解しないんだから成り立っているんです
特に経済的な世界では
相手がいなかったら自分が儲からないんです
品物やらサービスやら買った人が
ああ良かった 良かったと
これで私は幸せになりましたと
大変役に立ちましたという気持ちがなければ
商売にならないんです
なんでその単純なことを理解しないんですかね
とにかく売れではないんです
なんとかしてなんとかして
とにかくもう売りなさいと
そういうことではなくて
コンシューマーの側も
いわゆる消費者の側も売ってくれないかと
私に必要ですよと あなたのサービス
あなたの品物 私に必要ですよと
というふうな状態にならないと
経済っていうのは流れません
あっちこっち引っかかっちゃうんです
経済引っかかったらどうしますかというと
また弱い者をいじめ ほんのちょっとでもアメリカの方の経済が間違っちゃったら
世界中すべての国々をいじめる
いじめて壊して潰して自分たちが儲かるようにする
で そういうどんな国でも力ある国々は同じことをやっているんです
相手を潰して儲かりました
それは一回きりなんですよ
この一回きりの経済学とお釈迦様おっしゃっている
ずっと続ける経済的な思考っていうのはまた別なんです
だからお釈迦様おっしゃっている経済的な方法っていうのは
世の中で人があまり実行していないんです
実行しようとしたっても
純粋に実行できないんですね
今の世の中で そこで私たちに考えられるのは
この 競争すると必ずも誰かがダメージを受けるんですよ
ダメージを受けること自体が慈しみの基準から逸れちゃいますね
そうすると基本的なところで間違ったんだから
必ずも不幸になってしまう
買って買って幸せになったという人がいません
すごい不幸になるんです
ものすごいどこかでかなりダメージを受けているんです
そういうことだから この
お釈迦様教えるのは 他人がいるんだから自分がいるんだという
他人のおかげで自分が生きているんだと
その考え方に基づいて
教育も経済学も政治も作ってみなさいよと
お釈迦様の時代で この政治的な問題にお釈迦様は大変ぶつかりましたから
なぜかというと この恐ろしい政治世界がその当時で始めたんですよ
独裁的な政治とか そこで
当時で自分の国を大きくしたしたい王様たちが平気で隣の国を攻める
攻めてその人々を殺しちゃって
これも自分の国だとつなげちゃうんですね
それは何なのかと なんで人々のことを放っておけないかと
で 昔今は難しいんだから
戦争をあまりしませんだけど
本当はしたい気持ちはみんなにあるんです
で 昔はね インドっていうのは大きな国ですから
一つの国ではなかったんだから
たくさんの国がありましたし
お釈迦様の時代でも１６の国に分けてありましたし
ですから この小さなある力のある国が隣の国を攻める
その人々が自分でもう幸せで生きてたのに
えらい迷惑なんでね 隣から軍隊が来て殺しちゃうと
そこで立ち上がって戦争しなくちゃいけないはめになっちゃうし
そうやって殺し合いやったところで強い人が勝ちます
強い人が勝ってこの国を負けたとしたっても
人々の心まで負けますかね
心ですごい悔しいでしょうに
だから自分の国だけ政治した方が安全安全なのに
隣の国も捕まって大きくしたところで
その王様の政治活動不安になるんです
もう国二つの国一つになりましたから
もうそれなりに政治しなくちゃいけないし
だから軍隊にもいろんな隣の負けた国の人々も入るでしょうに
だから安心して寝られなくなるんですよ
結果はそれだけ だから昔からもう王様たちっていうのはすごい軍隊にも守られて
自分で刑務所を作ってるような感じで隠れて隠れて生活しているんです
それで頭が悪いんだから
私は偉大なる王やとすごい贅沢しているんだと
また嘘ばっかり言ってるんです
いくら贅沢な品物に恵まれあっても
自分が誰かに殺されるんではないかと
そういう怯えて生活することを幸せですかね
自分の宮殿から下りて
ほんのちょっとそこら辺散歩できますかね
散歩しちゃったら誰かにやられちゃいますから
だから当時の世界で王様が散歩するったければ
もう自分の宮殿のその中か
あるいはずっと軍隊と一緒に散歩をするかということになったでしょうし
なんでそういうアホなことをするんですかと
だから昔からも まあ私は経済から政治に入りましたけど
政治の世界を考えてみると
誰一人も安心して政治活動できないんですね
国民のためにであろうか
自分のためであろうか
政治家はちょっとわからない連中ですけど
まあその活動は何一つもできないんですね
なぜかというと どんどんどんどん昔は国を広げて広げて大きくしようと
大きくしようとすると
結局敵が増えるだけ その問題に一人の王様だけ気づいたんです
それは紀元前243年あたりで即位したダルマアショーカという王様なんですけど
インドで 彼も昔の人々に倣って
かなり力強い恐ろしい人でしたし
とことんもう隣 隣 隣 殺して殺して殺して国を広げていったんですね
そこで南の方にカーリンガという国がありまして
そのカーリンガという国も攻めなくちゃいけないんだと
攻めたんですね でもカーリンガの人々っていうのは
自分の国を守るために必死で頑張ったんです
それで何10万人も人が死んじゃったんです
そこでその王様はそれを見て
自分がただ国を大きくしたいだけ
でもその人々が必死になって力もないのに戦うんですよ
国を守ろうとして みんな死んで死んでいくんです
王様の軍隊はもう残酷にも出る
出る人はみんな女であろうが男であろうがかまわず殺しちゃう
それでその人が自分が一体何やってるんですかと悩んだところで仏教に出会うんです
それもすごい ものすごいお坊さんに出会ったわけじゃなくて
ストーリーによると まあ子供のお坊さんに出会ったんです
何10万人も20万人か
その王様ちゃんと書いてますよ
このこれぐらい人死にましたと
この戦争でちゃんと記録しているんです
それで悩んでいる時 ストーリーによると小さな子供なんですけど
出家して歩いているのをこの王様が見たんですね
そしたらその子は何て幸せかと
何一つも心の中で問題ない
落ち着いて道路で歩いているのを見たら
もうなんか不思議だなと思って
で 宮殿に呼んだそうで
宮殿に呼ばれたっても
全然ビクビクすることもないし
怖がることもないし 驚くこともないし
普通に歩いて宮殿の中に入る
そしたらこの巨大な偉大なる王様のところに来るんですけど
この人はそれでも落ち着いているんだと
全然周りに際しても 何一つにも驚きもびっくりも怖がることも何もないんだと
これ不思議だと それで
じゃああなたはね 自分にふさわしいところにお座りになってくださいと
王様はわからないんだから
この出家者にどんな風に対応すればいいかとわからないでしょうし
ですから あんたこっち座れと言えばいいんだけど
それわからないんだから
自分で決めて自分の立場に合う席に座ってくださいと言った
言われたところで その子供のお坊さんが周りを見て
王様の手をつかまって玉座に乗って座ったんだと
手をつかまったのはもう届きませんだから
椅子が高いんだから それに王様怒ったんじゃないんです
何のことなく自分の手をつかまってそちらに座ったんだから
あ この人が子供なんですけど
何か人間には答えを持ってるんではないかと
それでその人の話を聞いて
それからその子供だからね
あまり説法することもそれほどできませんし
その子供の先生 大変な有名な大阿羅漢で
その先生からずっと仏教を学んだんです
ことごとく学んだんです
学んで 歴史上 地球の歴史上初めて
王っていうのは 本当の王っていうのは戦争するものではなくて
戦争をやめる人やと 戦いをやめる人こそ王様やと言って
彼が初めてこの碑文として全部石に彫って
自分のメッセージとかね
インドにありますし 歴史のテキスト読めば大体どなたにでも日本訳もありますしね
アショーカ碑文という
書いてるんです 私は今まで戦争の太鼓を叩いて生きてきましたと
これから人間には真理のメッセージを伝える太鼓を叩きますよと
ダンマデーリという言葉が書いてあります
だから彼が一旦この平和をっていうのは
みんなを殺す人ではなくて
守る人やと 戦う人ではないんだと
潰す人ではないんだとわかって
その行動をしたんだから
彼にあの巨大なインド
彼初めてなんですよ ものすごくインドを全体的に一つにまとめたのは
でも問題なく 自分の政治時代では平和でインドを守ったんですね
で 彼がもう人間にだけではなくて
動物にまで病院作っちゃったんです
王は人間だけじゃなくて
国の動植物も守らなくてはいけないんだと
壊してはいけませんと
昔は肉とかいろいろ食べていたんだけど
全部どんどんやめちゃって
自分が肉食べるんだから動物殺されるんだと
で 控えて控えて 最終的にはもう全部やめてしまったんです
自分が王様だから たとえ肉を食べたっても
動物匹死んじゃうんだと
それは王として守るべき生命を守らなかったことになるんだと
ということでやめちゃったんです
動物にまで病院作りましたからね
そこである日分でこう書くんですよ
私は国民の父親である
国民は私の子供たちですよ
だから私はお妃たちとあの宮殿の中にいる時でも
たとえトイレに行っている時でも
誰かの何か悩み事があったら遠慮しないですぐ私に報告しなさいと
あちこち碑文に書いてつけておくんです
だからお釈迦様は歴史的にいた本物の人間だったよということは
科学的に証明できたのも
その王様のおかげなんでしょうし
ルンビニにここお釈迦様がここに生まれましたよという柱を作ったのはこの王様なんです
イヘタターガトジャートという言葉を書いて
私がこの年でこちらに来てお参りに来ましたよと
今インドの紋章がこのアショーカ王様の紋章なんです
その中にちゃんと法輪があるんです
真ん中 今日本でもよく使っている法輪がありますね
仏教の紋章ですから 法輪は
ですから 仏教的に政治も経済も教育もやるならば
誰にも迷惑をかけないんですよ
誰にも迷惑をかけないということは
みんな幸せということなんです
なんで自分が幸せになるために
また誰かが悲しまなくてはならないんですかね
それで面白いんですかね
人を潰して 誰かを潰して
今 金融関係のいろいろ商売やるでしょ
人が悩んでるところに狙い定めて
で いっぱいビラをもう何の保証もなしにお金貸してあげますよと
いろんなところに狙い定めてお金貸してあげたりする
それでも払えない利息っていうのはものすごい恐ろしくて
それで結局その人が潰れる
命までなくなる時もある
それで一人の人が儲かっちゃう
あれで面白いんですかね
そんな商売続けますかね
だから経済学にしたっても
もう何百年でも続けるようにしておかないと
人間が生きる限り経済活動はしなくてはならないでしょうに
我々の世代で全て終わっちゃったんだと言ったら
我々の生き方は正しいんですかね
孫 ひい孫の時代じゃなくて
人類がいる限り幸せで生きていられるようなシステムでなきゃならないでしょうに
だから我々今習っている考え方というのは
もうとにかく相手を潰す
その場で儲かると イソップ物語にちょっと面白いストーリーがあるんです
ある貧しい家に なんとかいい人々なんですけど
あるどんな鳥か鶏かあまり昔々読んだストーリーでははっきりわかりませんだけど
この人々が貧しいんだから
もう何とかしてあげなくちゃいけないと
この鳥の羽が金なんです
その家で金の羽を枚を落としていくんです
だからこの鶏にとっても羽枚ぐらいはもうね
何のことないんだから
すぐ出ますから そこでそれを売ってこの家が豊かになるんです
また来て また枚下ろしていく
そこで奥さんかもう旦那さんかちょっと覚えてないんだけど
こんなこの鶏はケチやと
あれほど体中金の羽がついているのに
一枚しか下ろしてくれないと
だから我々はそれを売ってなんとか何とか必要なものを買ったら
もうもうすぐ全部お金終わっちゃいますと
すごいすごい建物をなんか作ってえらい豊かにはなれないんだと
いくら待ってもこんな調子だと経済状態は
だから今度来たら鶏を捕まって全部羽取りましょうと
そうするといっぺん大金入りますから
すぐ豊かになる だから経済学的に正しいんですよ
考え方は 現代経済学的に
例えば その日のその日の生活費だけもらうと大金持ちにならないでしょ
その日にだけ豊かに生きていられるぐらい収入がある
で 次の日もそれなりの収入があると
その人はもう大金持ちになってすごい建物を造って豪邸を造って生活することはできないんです
だからいっぺんに大金もらった方がいいんじゃないかっていう現代的な考え方なんですよ
で ニワトリをまあ捕まろうと
それでまあ夫婦一人が反対するんですよ
これはけしからんだと
そのニワトリさんが大変親切に我々のことを優しく思っているんだから
そうやって 1枚1枚くれてるんではないか
だからなんで捕まる必要ありますかと
あなたの考え方で言ったら
ずっと我々はこのまんまですよと
成功はしませんと と言ってニワトリを捕まるでしょ
捕まって全部種を引っ張るんですね
引っ張ってみたら 1つも金じゃないんです
で ニワトリはもう二度と来なかったんです
それで全部終わりと だから現代の我々の生き方もそういう生き方なんですね
一発勝負やと思って それで自然も壊して
水も壊して 海も壊して
空気も壊して 体まで壊して
環境も壊して 私はすごく疑問に思いますよ
なんでこの子供たちとか
突然いきなり変になっちゃうんですかと
おそらくもう環境の問題もあると思いますよ
突然凶暴になって誰かを殺したりする
本人も何やったかとわからない
だからこの壊し屋論理では不幸しかないんです
そういうことだからもう相手が幸せでいると自分が幸せなんです
それを忘れているんですね
だからアショーカという王様が本当に政治が政治活動はどのようにするべきかということは
仏教徒になってからちゃんと教えたんです
で 彼が仏教徒ですか あるいは政治家だからどんな宗教も応援していたんではないかという疑問も学者の間であるんです
我々仏教徒だから もう彼が正真正銘の仏教徒ですよと言ってますけど
インドの歴史学者たちがそう言いたくないんです
それは個人の好みで もう学問もいじりいじりまくっちゃいますからね
まあそれはどっちでもいいんだけど
なぜかというと 彼がこのいろんな碑文にこう書くんですよ
自分に信仰あるんだから言って
他人の信仰をけなしてはいけませんと
他人の宗教をけなす人
けなす人が自分の宗教をけなしているんだと
そちらにもあるのは 競争論理に反対する共存の論理なんです
自分の自分が信仰している宗教の開祖様であろう
神様であろうか その人に対して自分が尊敬したければ
他の宗教を信じる人々のこともちゃんと大事に考えなくてはならない
お釈迦様おっしゃっている言葉なんです
だから 彼が仏教徒であるということが決まる決まり文句がありまして
ある碑文に彼がお坊さんたちにも説教するんです
私はブッダとお坊さんたちには大変尊敬しているんだと
このお坊さんたちももうちょっとこういうこういう経典勉強して生活するんだったらありがたいんだよと
だからそこまで言えるぐらい知識あるっていうことは
もうお坊さんたちにも説教するんだから
本当に父親なんです これ
宗教の世界だから私に関係ないんだということじゃなくて
私の国にいる人々だから
いい加減な坊主やっちゃったら困るんだと
だったらちゃんとお釈迦様がおっしゃったとおりに
このありえわせとか まあ今思い出すのはありえワサニという言葉なんですけど
このありえワンサというパーリ語の経典で結構難しいんですよ
かなり厳しくお釈迦様
お坊さんたちを戒めている経典なんです
そういうところは勉強してほしいんだと
だからそこまで言えるということで
もう彼が仏教徒であったことは確かですよ
でも政治家として他の宗教は守らなくてはいけないんだから
ちゃんとその他の全ての宗教をちゃんと守ってあげたんですね
で 自分の国の王様たちも
この植民地になるちょっと前まではちゃんと仏教的に政治やっていたんですね
ですから 自分の国でも歴史はちゃんと書いてますから
よく出てきますよ 王様っていうのは何のことなくあっちこっち歩いてみる
誰も気づかないんです
軍隊も何もなくて だからいろんな村やら地方やら一人で出かけて歩いてみる
何のために歩くかというと
王様として行ったらみんなごまかしやるんだから
本当の苦しみのやのは言ってくれないんだと
ですから 普通の人間として行って
そこでそこら辺の村人分かっても
王様っていうことは何のことなく
もうご飯作ってあげたりはしていたみたいし
だからそこまで国民のために行動しなくてはいけないんだと
立派でしょうに そういう生き方っていうのは
ある王様がお寺で育てたんですよ
子供の時から お寺で育てて
大人になったところで
自分の父親が死んじゃったところで王にならなくちゃいけないんですね
彼が断るんです 私はもうなりたくないんだと
めんどくさいんだと そしたらお坊さんたちがあんた何言うんですかと
長男だから王にならなきゃ国民を守れませんと
お坊さんたちがちゃんと私
何か間違い事をしたら教えてくれるんだったらやりますよってことで
彼に教えたお坊さん 彼のおじさんでしたけど
出家してたおじさんでしたからね
一応王になって 王になったところで
まあ仏教的な政治だからすごく優しくて
誰もあまり王様すごいとかそんな怖がることもなく
もう軽々く ごく普通の家族の雰囲気でやってるんですね
弟がいる 弟はそうじゃないんです
すごい我が強くて 王は王らしくやらなくちゃいけないんだと
お兄ちゃんがすごい生ぬるいんだと
それで政治できませんと
生ぬるいという一つの理由は
いろいろ犯罪とかね したら人々を捕まったりするでしょうに
捕まったら王は王としてちゃんと審判を受けて刑務所とかに決める
あんた刑務所やと 決めても終わってから日
二日経つと王様がそこら辺に行くんです
刑務所に んで なんであんたこちらにいるんですか
私はこういうことで刑務所にいると言うわけ
そうか じゃあまあ帰れと
帰ってしっかり普通の人間としてちゃんと生活しなさいよと
言って援助してあげる
だからなんとか犯罪 人殺しとか
そこまではなかったと思いますけど
ほとんど泥棒とかね そんなもんですけど
結局後で王様からいろいろ財産もらって帰っちゃいますから
帰って普通の生活する
それはもう怒り持ってる人間にとっては悔しいんですね
そういう弱いところをいじっちゃって
この人がそんなことをやったらもう犯罪増えるだけではないかとかね
で 弟がもうちょっと違う立場を取ったんですね
そしたらこのお兄ちゃんの王様が何したんですかというと
じゃああんたやりたければあんたやってくださいと
自分が帰るんです 王をやめて
そんなことで喧嘩する必要ないんだと
弟と兄ちゃんが軍隊二つ作って戦争しちゃったら
死ぬのは国の国民だよと
王は両方守らなくてはいけないんだと
国民だから これ外国から来たら話は別ですけど
だから自分が国の中で騒乱を起こすようなことはしませんと
やめましたと 言ってきれいさっぱり王をやめるんです
そこでお兄ちゃんがあれぐらいの王をやめちゃったんだから
恐ろしい政治は弟にもできないんです
でも弟はしっかりした政治家で
国民にはもうこんなことをやられたらもう嫌われるんだということをよくわかって
もう彼は彼なりにすごいしっかりと政治を
活動をやっていたんですね
そういういっぱいいろんな昔のね
仏教的に政治やった王様たちの話がもうあるんです
人殺しの話じゃないんです
だってどう考えたっても
自分の国はスリランカというのはすごい小さいんですよ
あの巨大なバカでかいインドのほう
南もう口の中にあるような感じでしょうに
でも一度も誰にも負けたことがないんです
イギリス人にも負けなかったんです
植民地になったんだけど
騙されただけなんです
で ポルトガル人 それからオランダ人
で 3番目にイギリス人
この1550年からもうどんどん順番できて
海の方で船を持ってきて
海でいるんですけど 国の中には入らないんです
なぜ入らないかとなぜ戦争できないかというと
スリランカでは軍隊はなかったんです
王様のところに 軍隊がいると戦えますけど
戦って王様は捕まりますけど
軍隊がないとどうすればいいんですかね
そこで結局国民みんな
女の人も子供もみんな結局国を守っているんです
だから外国の軍隊動かないんです
だから軍隊が動いたっても
普通の村人たちだから
全然反対もしないし だから戦えないでしょうに
こうやって通っていったって
何のことなくいるんですね
そこで一旦国の中に入ったところで
結局戻れなくなっちゃうんですね
どこから来たかどうかわからなくなっちゃうんです
国民がじゃあどうぞ行ってくださいって
この道も全部もう消えさせて回ってる
だからこれ王様がやらせるんじゃないんです
そちらのそちらの地方の人々が
そこで帰るときはもう道がなくて
行くところがなくて 間違ってもう迷子になったりして
もう大惨事なんです 自分たちのことだから
帰っても動かないんだと
国の真ん中のカンディというところの方に
だからそれで国をちょっと騙して
国民を騙して王様を捕まったんだけど
その時も国の大臣たちがあんた方は勝ったわけじゃないんだと
王は悪かったんだから
最後の王っていうのはすごくおかしかったんです
仏教的ではなかったんです
かなり人殺しちゃったんです
それに国民が怒ったんです
あんた人殺すんだったら王じゃないんだと
だからこんないらんものは
あれほどイギリス人が欲しがってるんだからあげるんだということであげちゃったんだよ
持っていってと いりませんと
なぜあげたかというと
自分たちでちゃんと仏教的な人を次に次の人を王にしたかったんですね
イギリス人はその合間で隙間でもう国を取ったんだということにしちゃったところで
世界で初めて契約書を書かせたんです
イギリス人に対して あなた方はこういうこういう項目を守るならば
国の管理を任せますと
だからそこはもう大変国では有名で
ちゃんと書いて 英語と国の言葉と書いて
みんなこの国の責任者たちがサインして
イギリスのガバナーですか
その人もサインして 国の権利を渡しちゃったんだけど
まあ 1ヶ月間経たないうちにあの公約破っちゃったんで
イギリス人が そこからもうまた戦ってきたんです
ですから 結局仏教的で行動したんだから
まあ負けたわけじゃないんです
コンディションは条件は国
こちらのスリランカ国で作ったんだから
負けたならば向こうは条件作るでしょ
だからイギリス人がちゃんと仏教を守ること
お寺やら全部守ること
スリランカ人の文化をちゃんと大事に守ることとか
そういう項目全部決めて
そこでガバナーがサインしたところで涙が流したみたいんですよ
そこまで誰にもできなかったんだと
この小さな国を捕まることは
でもやっと偉大なるイギリスの神様の国の一つになりましたと
そこからもうちゃんと仏教は守ってきましたし
頑張りましたし それからどんどんどんどん崩れていきましたけど
とにかく言いたがっているのは
この仏教的に行動するならば
負けるということはないんです
最近のスリランカ すごくもう経済的にも政治的にもものすごくおかしくなりましたけど
それも仏教を捨てちゃったんです
政治家が 仏教を捨てて
まあ西洋的な価値観でやるぞと
その日から人は死んでいくんです
戦いやらもう内戦やらもう切りがないんです
仏教的でやった時は全然そういうこと
人死んだっていうことはない
人を殺すっていうことはもう聞いたこともない
私は子供の時は 今はもう毎日
ですから 慈しみに基づいて行動すると
我々のは一度も味わったことがない
大変素晴らしい世界が生まれてくるんです
誰の権利も奪わない 美しい世界が生まれてくるはずなんです
じゃあ次の問題はこの
今の世界で我々のは仏教の国を作ることができませんだからね
私たち個人個人でどう頑張ればいいかということなんですよ
今更いくら私は叫んだっても
西洋的な価値観から脱出できませんし
もう破壊した自然は戻りませんしね
でも今でも例えば日本の国でも
今日から仏教的な競争をやめて
共存的な方法で経済活動をやるぞと思ったら
明日から幸せになります
そんな問題ないんですけど
やり方がありますけどね
そういうのを具体的にこの場合はこうします
この場合はこうします
この場合はこうしますということだからね
私にはそんな公では言えるものではないんです
聞くならばちゃんと答えます
こういう問題どうすればいいか
その場合こうしますよと
だから心にあってほしいのは
誰も損してはいけないという
たったそれだけなんです
どんなものであろうか
株 株の売買であろうか
他の商売であろうか 誰も損してはいけないんだと
一人が損してもう一部が得するんだったら
それは正しくないんだよと
何か対策を決める場合は
みんなに賛成できるかないかと
ただそれだけで決めればいいんです
例えば国会とかそういうところでいろんな議論ができるでしょうに
できるんだけど 一部は賛成なんですけど
一部は反対なんですね
ああいう議論は仏教的じゃないんです
仏教的っていうのはとことん議論して
両者もあ それならいいんだというところまで議論を成長させなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから今ろくに議論もしないんですよ
多数決で潰す この多数決で潰すということは
仏教的な民主主義じゃないんです
お釈迦様は民主主義者でしたから
お釈迦様の民主主義っていうのは
多数決で潰すことではありません
反対側ととことん話し合う
議論する 議論して 一つ一つの問題ポイントを解決していく
一旦解決したら 反対側も賛成しなくちゃいけないんです
そこでお釈迦様は多数決で潰せっていうところはあるところあります
それどういう時かというと
この反対側は何の決まりも守れません
ただ反対だそれだけ 相手の何かいい結論出したいではなくて
相手側潰したい ただそれだけの気持ちで反対のために反対であってであって
いくら論理的に自分が負けたとしても
それでも反対ですよと言うんだったら話にならないでしょうに
その場合は相手は真理にのっとってないんだと
事実は事実として認めたくないんだと
ただ反対のために反対しているだけですよと
ただ このいい考え方を壊したいだけですよと
その場合は多数決で潰せと
その一箇所だけで多数決は決めているんです
そうでない限りは 反対意見の人々もいいことをしたいと思うなら
例えば政治家の場合は野党与党両方あるでしょうに
選挙で勝ったら野党の方も政治権利を取るでしょうに
だからみんな基本的に真理というのは国を守ることをみんなの責任なんです
たとえ野党であろうが与党であろうが
国民の幸せをみんな当たり前で認めなくちゃいけないんです
その一つの目的にみんな絞って議論すればいいんです
この提案はどういうことかと
これはこういうわけでいけないんだよと
じゃあだったらどうすればいいんですかと言って
どんどんどんどん提案改良させて
じゃあだったらじゃあこれだったら OK やと言って
千人一致で決めなくちゃいけないんですよ
それはお釈迦様の民主主義なんです
千人一致ということは
現代西洋的な民主主義っていうのは
大勢の人々の権利を奪うことなんです
例えば５つの党があるとする ５
つの党が選挙に出る そうすると
何て言いますか 過半数取った人は政権取るでしょ
そこで他の４つの党が得た投票を計算してみると
政権取ってる人々の投票よりは多いんでしょうに
だから賛成している人の方が少なくて
反対している人の方が多い場合というのはいくつでもいつでもあり得るんです
それを民主主義とは言いきれますとはちょっと言いにくいんですね
だから仏教的というのは
ものすごい根本的に もうものすごい変えなくちゃいけないんですよ
人間一度でも慈悲に 慈しみに基づいて物事を考えたことがないんだから
とにかく政治の場合でもそういうことで
何か決める時でも 我々はやっぱり誰も損しないようにということだけ頭の中で覚えておけば
人を悲しませて自分が楽しくなるっていうことはもうありえないことなんです
あれはそういう道なんですね
そこでまたポイントに戻りますけど
この世の中で我々には世の中を変えることはできませんし
どうせ学問は競争でしょうし
商売も競争でしょうしとか
そこで競争しなかったら
もう自分には食べていられないのではないかと
その場合もやり方があるんです
例えば学校に行ったら相手がライバルだと思う
本当に自分が 1番目になりたくて頑張っちゃうとする
それは普通の学問でしょ
学校の教育方法でしょ
あれでいい結果になってますかというと
なってないでしょうに
子供は学校に行きたくないという
それでも強引に行きなさいと言っちゃうと自殺する
ドロップアウトはいくらでも出てくる
地獄の苦しみなんです
そこで問題は 相手がライバルで相手に勝たなくちゃいけない
あの人に勝たなくちゃいけないと
ただそれだけ考えてるんだから
本人すごく精神的に苦しみを味わう
不安になる 怯える 弱い人だったら学校なんかすごく怖く感じる
それでどうなるかというと
その本人が持っている能力は一つも機能しなくなっちゃうんです
一人一人の人間が何かの能力を持ってるんです
今の教育世界では 日本だけじゃなくて世界中同じですから
人間持っている能力を潰してるんです
だから教育水準は高いと威張っても
実際の結果は全く違うんです
例えば東大出ればよろしいかと思ったっても
だからそこを出る人々はみんな才能抜群かと
日本語を管理するぐらいの能力
まるっきり違うんです
ただ 決まってる決まりを守って
決まってる教育方法を丸暗記したりして操り人形なんです
だからうまく操る人形になった人が引いてるレールに乗って行って
いくらか金儲けて生活しているだけで
抜群な大胆な人間一人も出てこない
世界一番でしょ 教育レベルは日本は
でも世界を驚かす人は一人もいません
みんなただのおじいさんおばあさんで終わっちゃうんです
世界一の教育水準高ければ
もう世界びっくりするほど人々がいっぱいいるはずなんですよ
もし子供に天才的な能力あると
あれ全部潰しちゃうんです
もしある子供が年は 6歳かもしれませんだけど
高校生よりもものすごい頭がいいんだと
一人で勉強してすごく何でもできるんだと
でもダメでしょ 小学校に行かなくちゃいけない
中学生に行かなきゃいけない
それでその子はものすごく苛立ちを作って自殺するか
不良に不良者になるか
どちらか この自殺したあるいろんな何人かの子供たちが書いた文章をテレビで聞いていたんだけど
私はこの子たちが本当にすごい才能があったのではないかと
いろんな方向へ これを潰されちゃったんだから
もう生きる意味がないんだと
ということは 気づいたことはいくつかのケースだったんだから
だからみんなに道があるんですよ
数学できないんだからといって人生はできないというのは何なのかと
[背景音楽]だからこの競争の教育の中でも
我々は生き延びるために何をするべきかというと
ライバルを作らない 学校に行ったら相手はライバルじゃないんです
自分の能力をとことん出してやるんだ
それで十分なんです 相手をライバルと思わないことと
自分持っている能力は何でもいいんだから
それはもうとことん出す
まあ数学は下手かもしれませんだけど
絵を描くことは随分簡単に軽々とできるかもしれません
それはもうとことんやる
それに凝ってしまって
数学の数学のテストの場合は
カニングでもしてなんとかやればいいんです
カニングはよくないんだけど
まあそれはまあ低い点数でいいんだと
あまり悩まないことなんです
それで開き直ればいいんです
私はそういうことはあんまり向いてないんだと
この間も子供とちょっと話してみたんだけど
で 聞いたんですね あんたどういう方が好きで
勉強はね どういう方が向いてないかと
そしたら その子はまあ国語はあまりやりたくないんだと
それだけ 別に別に私は説教しなかった
ああそう じゃあ君は好きな学問が項目は何でしょうかと
こういうこういうことです
ああ そうですかと それだけ
それで子供はすごく落ち着いちゃったんです
そこで本人がみんなに言われるんだから言われることをやれないんですよ
自信がなくて 私はそれでそういうことだよ
人間にはいろいろ向きも不向きもありますよと
だから安心しなよと しなさいよと
どうったことないんだと
君が今自信がないと思ってるでしょ
自信がある人は一人いませんと
あれは嘘やとみんな言ってるの
自信があるんだとかね
よく見てみなさいよと
だから君が自信がないとか言って暗くなって
あの なみこみ 引きこみ
引っ込みの少年でしたけどね
そうなる必要ないやと
ちょっとまあもうちょっと30分ぐらいしゃべっただけで
まあ一緒に瞑想もしましたけど
何もやりたくない子なんですけど
真面目に瞑想したんです
大人と一緒に 瞑想を始めたら私は言ったんです
今からはあなたは一人前扱いますよと
二人で話した時は子供としてかわいがってあげたんだけど
瞑想始めたらあんた一人前
みんなと同じやと やってくださいと
ちゃんと理解して みんなと一緒に同じく一緒にやりましたし
私はもし点数をあげるんだったら
あの子が一番他の人よりも高い点数を取ったんです
瞑想で お父さんにも言った
あんたもやりなさいと
お父さんがまるっきり駄目で精神的に不安定で
全然落ち着きがなかったんです
それは言わなかったんだけど
まるっきり落ち着けないこの子は恐らく自殺するかもしれませんと怖くなっていたのに
その父親があの子はちゃんとやって
すごく明るくなって ニコニコと人と喋れないんだけど
みんなにちゃんと礼をして挨拶をして終わって帰ったんですね
全部全部自発的に ですからそのだからこの今の競争の世界で
我々は相手に勝つんじゃなくて
自分持ってる能力をとことん磨いてとことん磨いていけばいいんです
だから人にあんた数学下手でしょうと
数学できなきゃダメですよと
あんた英語できなきゃダメですよとかね
言われるとみんな落ち込んじゃうんです
自分が音楽は好きでいいんだけど
才能あるんだけど 絵も描けるんだけど
やっぱり英語ダメだからうまくいかないんではないかと
それで持ってる能力が出てこなくなっちゃうんですね
それは競争の論理を作る大変な悪い結果なんです
だから何かできなくたっても何をと
例えば私はまるっきり絵なんかは描けません
全然それで引っ込みにはなりません
描けませんよと だから何ですかと
描ける人はあんた描いてくれと
私もいろいろ時々イラストなんか必要になっちゃいますけど
こちらのメンバーでいるゆうこさん
高橋優子さん 優子さんに頼んで
優子さんちょっとイラスト描いてくれませんかと頼んで描いてもらうんです
国にいろいろ年賀状やらいろんな出しされしなくちゃいけないし
その時はまあ頼んで描いてもらう
本当は普通の常識では自分で描いて出した方がいいかもしれません
描けないんだからしょうがないでしょうに
それは恥ずかしいとも全然思わない
それで自分持っている能力は自分で思い存分出す
それで他人の能力も必要だったら
そことすごくいい人の能力を借りてもらうと
そうやっていい社会はできあがっちゃうんです
決まってる項目ばっかり全部みんな高い点数取らなくちゃいけないんだと思っても
もう万能な人を作るというのは
それはありえないんです
万能な人っていうのはかえって迷惑なんです
なぜかというと 一つもできませんから
協力しないんです 例えば
今の日本の政府の場合は
この小渕さんですか 結構うまく政治やってるんですよ
なぜうまいかというと
なんかどう見たってもう何もできないような
何もできない まあ我々
私の主観かもしれませんだけど
この人何もできないような感じでしょうという感覚があるんですね
それで彼がみんなに言ってお願いします
土下座までしてお願いします
だからみんな協力しているんです
だから 他の大臣の方々はね
一生懸命小渕さんを守ってあげようと頑張っているでしょうに
あれ すごくいいと思いますけどね
お互いにすごい協力し合って何とかしようではないか
だからそれでいいんですよ
全て自分にできるようなことだったら
誰も協力しないんです
絶えてしまっちゃうんです
でも人間っていうのはそんなにも力あるわけじゃないんですよ
すぐ疲れますから 時間も時間しかないんだから
1 日 そのなんだかんだもできるわけじゃないんです
だから 一人一人が自分持っている能力だけ出せばいいんです
そこは思い存分出せばいいんです
できないところは堂々と開き直って胸を張ってできませんと
だからあなたにお願いしますと
そういう生き方っていうのは
子供の時から身についちゃうと
子供をお互いに仲良くするんですよ
お互いに助け合っているんだから
例えば算数は上手な人は下手な子供たちにちょっとずつ助けてあげたりする
絵の上手な人は絵を描けない子供たちにちょっとちょっと助け合ったりすると
お互いに喧嘩する必要なくなっちゃうんです
わしらは古い時代の人間だから
学校に行った時はいつでもそういう生き方やっていたんです
自分できることをみんなに教えてあげたりする
そこで自分にできないことは何のことなくお願いする
君やってくださいと 特に私はあまり体力なくて
体すごい小さかったし
小さい時は教室のみんなかなり体格が良かったんですね
そこでこのデスクの上の勉強っていうのは
私はもう 1番目で体力必要な時は私はもうダメで
でもいろいろ宿題いろんなものあります
体力が必要なんですね
そういうことをみんな各自でやらなくちゃいけないんだけど
私は自分のことをやろうとすると
かなり体力で体格のある友達が来て
何のことなく何も言わないんですね
こそこそさささささってやってくれて
はいどうぞと 私は待ってるだけで十分なんです
それでみんなまあうまくいく
君もよくやってるんだなと先生にも褒められるし
だから一つ地図一つ立体で地図作らなくちゃいけないということになって
立体のあれだから まずもう台を大きく作らなくちゃいけなかったんです
小さい友達のこの板とか持ってきて
これ鋸で切って また釘を打って砕いて
あれ大変なことなんですね
そのクラスですごい体格のいい子がいて
それは何のことなく 私のところから鋸を引っ張って
自分でもうちゃんとささささささっと切っちゃうんですね
切って台を作って そこで立体的に作るために必要なものを作ると
これは他に何人か作ってくれたんですね
そこで一番知識必要なのは
このまず図を描いて 地図ですから
地図を描いて そこは私がやって地図を描いてあげた
それでちゃんと基本的なところ
そちら作ったら 私はもう勉強しながらいろいろコントゥアーとかいろいろありますから
山とか川とかね そういうのをちゃんと丁寧に
もうちゃんと私はそれ作って作って終わっちゃうと
その山川とか それちゃんと区別できるように色を塗らなくちゃいけないでしょうね
それは絵を描ける上手な人に
じゃあ君 こういう風に塗ってくださいと
そしたら真面目に塗ってくれる
そうやったら またいろんな場所を示すために
いろんな絵を描いて いろんなところに貼らなくちゃいけない
自分が絵を描けないんですね
そこをやっている途中でもうあんたね
こういう絵とこういう絵とこういう絵と
これぐらいの小さい大きさで描いてくれと
その子はそれ描くんですね
最後に私は全部必要なところに貼って
で  OKと 先生から見たらびっくりするだけ
やっぱりこんなに正確に厳密にできるかと
ちゃんとプロが作ったような感じで
子供の頃 厳密に作っておいたんです
だからみんなの協力なんですね
もし私が全部できたならば
一人でやろうとするでしょう
そうすると失敗でしょ
自分が疲れるし 楽しくもないし
だからその作業をやった時
昔話の作業をやった時だけでも
結局ただ楽しいだけなんです
あっち走ったり こっち走ったり
いろんなことやったら体力ある子はもう全然頭が悪かったんだから
その子もすごい気分がいいんです
俺が作った大帝城ということで
私たちももうそれはちゃんとね
こいつはバカだからもう関係ないやということにならないでしょうね
ものすごい協力してくれたんだから
だから結果としてみんなすごい
そこで勉強よりは 我々にとってはただの遊んだだけのことなんですね
同時にちゃんと勉強にもなりましたし
ですから この競争の世界
競争するんだ 競争するんだということではなくて
自分持っている能力だけ出せばいいんです
なぜかというと 世の中っていうのはいろんな能力を必要としているんです
我々は社会で生きてるんです
社会っていうのは一人という意味じゃないでしょ
ですから この能力ないことはすごくいいことなんです
悪いことじゃないんです
英語をしゃべれない人がいるでしょ
あれすごいいいことなんです
それで日本でものすごい英語をしゃべる人見るでしょ
あれもすごいいいことなんです
だから我々には何かの能力があって
またすごいない能力の方が多いんです
そこは我々の幸せのためにあるシステムなんです
なんでそれ壊そうとしているんですかね
みんな平らにしてやろうとかね
なりっこはないんだから
だから自分に能力ないことも自慢にしなくちゃいけないし
自分に能力あることも自慢にしなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで 今の競争が激しい世界で生きていられるんです
競争が激しい世界で 自分に能力あるところはきちんともう思い存分出してないところではちょっとお願いしますと
そちらある人が思い存分能力ある人が助けてくれたら
結果は完璧でしょ だから負けません
どちらでも で 経済の世界でも同じことで
例えば会社にいてリストラになるんじゃないかなと怖がっているでしょうに
それは何でしょうかというと
みんなもう決まってることばっかしやって
それで給料もらって家に帰ると
このワンパターンでやってるんだから
リストラになる恐れがあるんです
でも どんな会社にしたって
も入る人は全く別々な人間なんです
みんな何か能力を持ってるんですよ
生まれつき その自分が持っている能力をとことん出す
出しちゃうと その人がいないと困りますねという状況は出来上がっちゃうんです
例えばデスクワークは下手な人がいるとします
でもその人はこの何て言いますか
人と会ってしゃべる場
話す場はすごい上手ですよと
言葉遣いとか行儀がいいんだと
全然怒りも何もしませんと
相手をすぐ笑わせて もう自分の考え方にすぐ
変えてしまうんだと 説得力あるんだと
で その人がその能力 自分にあるんだから
いつでも他の人の仕事までやってあげると
人と喋ることだったら
まあじゃあ私がやってあげますよと
自分の管轄ではないかもしれません
それでも誰かお客さんとトラブっちゃったところで
その人の仕事だから勝手にやれということじゃなくて
ちょっと待って 私がやってあげますと
で どういうことかというと
その話をうまく解決してあげると
他のところでも何かあったらそこまでうまくやってあげると
そうすると会社にとっては
この人は本当に仕事は下手なんですけど
やっぱりなくてはならないんだと
なぜかというと お客さんとかトラブったところで
この人が言ってしまったところでうまくいくんだと
そうやってどこかで自分の能力を生かすところがあるんです
この間 木曜日の同じ質問をされちゃったところで
私はその人に言ったのは
自分が仕事をするときはね
何か言われたら じゃあ辞めてやると
そう言われるんだったら
私は辞めてやる それぐらいの気持ちでやらなくちゃいけないんだと
辞めてやると脅しちゃったら
会社の方が困るんだったら
あなたはちゃんと仕事してるんだと
だから我々にはそういう自信がありますかね
自分がやる仕事は もし何か言われると
嫌味を言われると だったら辞めてやるぞと言えるぐらいでやってるんだったら
この世の中で負けません
辞めてやるぞと言われる人が自分の仕事をちゃんとやってるんです
そこでこの 相手も負けないし
自分も負けないし  ポイントはまだたくさんありますけど
時間だけはない で それからお釈迦様が本当にどんな人間になって欲しかったかというと
みんなすごい合理的で
物事を客観的に見られる強い人間になって欲しかったんです
腰抜けは嫌でしたから
すごくお釈迦様批判しているんです
この弱くてこのグニャグニャの性格
これはお釈迦様はすごくもう批判するんです
だから性格はしっかりしているんだけど
頑固さはまたすごくダメですよと
頑固っていうことは物事を理解しないんです
柔軟性は必要なんですけど
だからといって ああそうですか
それもその通りで これもその通りですよといういい加減さも嫌でしたし
だからこの違う例で説明しますけど
宗教でいえば必ずしもついてくるものが祈りなんです
宗教イコール祈りという風になっているでしょ
仏教では残念ながらないんですよ
祈りは なぜ宗教なのに仏教で祈りないんですかと
祈りっていうのは 人の成長そのまま止まることなんです
祈ってみてください 精神的には同じところでずっといるんです
弱いまんまで なぜ人類が祈りという習慣を作ったかというと
この世の中でいろんなこの自分に乗り越えられない問題に出会うんです
病気になるわ 洪水でもう家は流されるわ
地震が起きて家が潰れるわ
突然人が死んじゃうと
いろんなことが起きるんです
人間にはそれはなかなかどうしようもないんですよ
その時は弱いんだから祈るんです
祈りというのは ちょっとした慰めだけ
祈ってうまくいくと思ったりする
仏教はそれはカットしているんです
やめてくださいと この間例に言いましたけど
あの  昨日の勉強会でも言ったことで
例えばその家族で二人の人が病気になったりする
突然そこで病院に運ぶ一人の家族の人が突然病気になったんだから
とにかく祈りしましょうと行って
いろんな神社 神社 お寺
どこでもいいんですけど
ありとこのところに行って一生懸命祈りすると
どうか早く治りますようにと
もう一人のお子さんが病院に行って
まあ看護婦さんにもあんたもよく頑張ってますねとかね
ああ 感動しましたと あんた方はね
毎日こんな大変なことをやらなくちゃいけないんだからね
お願いしますと お世話になりますと
お医者さんも診察する時はね
先生もなかなか若いんですねとかね
ちょっとお世辞一言葉言うと
そうやって病院の人々の機嫌を明るくしてあげる
あるいはまあ家のもう人はね
本当にうるさいんだからね
申し訳ないけど気をつけてくださいよとか何とか言って
まあこの病院の関わり合う人々に人のことを明るくしてあげる
どちらの方がいいんですかね？どちらの方が早く成功するんですかね
やっぱり論理的に病院に行ったんだから
お医者さんの態度やら看護婦さんの態度やら
そこは病気を早く治るために必要なことでしょうし
看護婦さんに対してすごくもう感謝したり
喜ばせてあげたり 機嫌を直してあげたりすると
患者さんがすごくその患者さん看護婦さんがその患者さんのことをすぐ覚えているでしょうね
そっちを行ってどうですか
どうですかとかね 聞くでしょうし
暇があったらちょっともう世間話の相手にでもなってあげるで
そういうことでさっさっと病気治るでしょうね
お医者さんの頭の中でも
その患者さんのことは忘れないように記憶されるでしょうね
だからそうやって知識
知識 知恵を使ってほしいんです
お祈りだけに行く人がその具体的な世界には行かないんですよ
普通の人間はそうじゃなくて
お医者さんに文句を言うんです
何ですか あなたの態度はとか
看護婦さんに文句を言うんです
これは法律的に文句を言える時もありますけど
でもそれでは結局はうまくいかない結果になるだけなんですね
だから仏教ってこの世の中で自分を守るためには
そういう鋭く知恵を使ってほしい
いちいち文句言って文句言って
正義の味方になって自分が殺される
潰されることではなくて
正義の味方を置いといて
この人の能力を引き出すためにどうすればいいんですかと
それだけ考えればいいんじゃないかなと
だから商売繁盛になりますようにと
リストラにならないようにとお祈りすると
一向に自分自身が成長しなくちゃいけないということに気が付かなくなっちゃうんです
お祈りしたんだから 八十八か所回ったんだからと
だから安心やと言って余計な安心がついちゃって
とんでもないことをしてしまう恐れもあります
もしお祈りみたいな簡単単純なことで物事うまくいくんだったら
人類は経済活動をやめてお祈りだけすればいいんです
神様もたくさんお金が入りますようにと
ストーリーだけでしょ
日本でもあるでしょ 七福神の話で何かあの
何か変なものを持って
それ振ったら金貨 小判が落ちるんだとかね
見たことがありますか？歴史上一回だけでも
その神様が小判を振ってくれたことは？ないでしょうに
だから七福神をお祈りしたりする人が結局ダメになっちゃう
ダメな人間になっちゃうんです
置いといて 自分のことを自分でやるんだと
自分の身の安全は自分でするんだと
という生き方なんですよ
現代世界で我々にある生き方っていうのは
そこで自分のことを守るためには
あなたが自分のことを守ってあげなくちゃいけないんだから
そこに鋭く知恵を使うと
だから知恵がどんどんどんどん開発しないと
毎日刺激的でないと いつでも毎日毎日何か問題にぶつかっちゃって
これどうすればいいかと
自分でそれに答えが探して見つかると
それですごく楽しみが生まれてくるんです
なんでみんなクイズとか好きですかね
クイズやらパズルやら
そういうもの好きでしょう
それはまず疑問なんですね
なぞなぞも好きでしょうに
だからこのなぞなぞ解くことで楽しいんです
だから毎日の生き方は全部もうなぞなぞにしちゃえば
毎日何か問題あるぞと
それはもうとにかく乗り越えるんだと
解決するんだと 見てみれば
この世の中そのまんまにあっても
仏教の人々は負けません
誰にも 誰にも負けませんだけど
誰にも負かせたことはないんです
誰も潰したことはないんです
病院に行ったら お医者さんはちょっと褒めてお医者さんのことを褒めてあげたと言って
お医者さんが負けるんですかね？負けないでしょうに
別に  [背景音楽]先生もまあ随分若いですね
やっぱりさすが頭良かったでしょうね
そんな年でそれぐらいのお医者さんに医者になったっていうことはすごいねとかね
言ってあげれば それも嘘言う必要ないんですよ
人には褒めるべきところはいくらでもありますから
例えば医者が白衣着ているとあまり格好悪かったとする
それでもその人は普通の制服を着てネクタイをはめたら普通の男前になる可能性あるでしょうに
それ言えばいいでしょうに
この医者はあんまりかっこ悪いなと思うんじゃなくて
先生も決まったらかなりなかなかかっこいい男でしょうと
なんとか言えばいいでしょうに
だから嘘言う必要も強いる必要もないんです
みんな何か持ってます
いいとこは そこは褒めてあげると
その人は負けたことがなくて
その人から私たちは得るべき能力を思い存分もらうだけのことで
それは搾取でも何でもないでしょうに
その人も楽しんだからよく頑張りましたと
ですから 仏教的な道っていうのは
そういうふうに両者も幸せになる
とにかく智慧っていうことは大変必要なんですね
祈りではなくて 祈りっていうのはもう本当に希望的観測だから暗いんでしょ
なぜ祈り聞かないかと
世の中でね ずっと歴史上
人類がね 文化始めた時からもう祈る一つも聞いてないんでしょうに
このバカでかい宮殿やら神殿やら全部潰れちゃったでしょうに
神様を信じてる国々ではすごい不幸ばっかしでしょう
戦う戦う 自然災害 祈りを置いておいてという国々は
特にこの上座部仏教の国々はそんなに災害
不幸とかがあっても乗り越えるということでやってますから
行ってみたら なんとなく幸せと平和というのを感じるだろうと思いますけど
いろいろトラブルは人間だからありますけど
あるんだけど もう泣いたり泣いたりとかないんですね
ですから この祈りするっていうことは
自分にないものをどんどんどんどん思い浮かぶことなんですよ
いわゆる心にあるこのネガティブ的な感覚
感情を育てるんです そうするとダメになっちゃうんです
だからそういう心理学的な
そこはちゃんと理解していないんだからね
まあ祈りはするんだけど
祈りする人々は別に悪い人間じゃないんですよ
まあそれはまあ それなりにちゃんと神を恐れて
ちゃんと正しく生活しているんですから
それは別に批判したくはないんだけど
で 人生成功するためにはそれほど影響はないんだと
人生は自分で作らなくちゃいけないし
自分の能力だけ出せばいいんですね
それであの人生のゲームというテキストにもこの説明で引用してありましたけど
ゲーム論というのはちょっと難しいんですけどね
これは簡単な枠の中で説明できるものではないし
あの とにかくまあ競争ではなくて
チャレンジしなくちゃいけないんですよ
生きることには 我々の命っていうのは
放っておいちゃうと堕落して死んじゃうんです
それは競争とは言えないんですよ
ご飯食べなかったら死ぬでしょうに
いい加減に外へ何も厚着も着ないで歩いちゃったら
寒くて震えて体が壊れるでしょうに
ちょっと不注意なことでも命がなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この常に 24時間
我々は注意深く生きていなくちゃいけないんですよ
それは相手が悪いというわけじゃないんです
相手が私を殺そうとしているというわけじゃないんです
だからこの空気の中でもいっぱいウイルスやら細菌やらあるんですよ
でも呼吸しなくちゃいけないし
そして肺の中でもし何かのウイルスでも何か定着しちゃったら
そこで病気になってしまっちゃうし
そういうことだから 人間というのはずっと常にチャレンジしなくちゃいけない
それは自分だけの勝負なんです
ウイルス入っても体が抵抗力を持ってるんだったらどうったことはないし
抵抗力なかったら病気になってしまっちゃうし
だから悪いのは自分なんですね
ウイルスが悪いんじゃないんです
ウイルスがずっとあるんだから
細菌がずっとあるんだから
そういうことだから この我々は常に注意深くこのチャレンジをしなくちゃいけないんですね
そこは私はゲームで このゲームって言ったっても
このこちらで書いてるようなテニスようなゲームじゃないんです
そんな単純じゃないんです
これはコンピューターゲームなんです
私は考えているのは コンピューターゲームの場合はもうやっちゃったら次から次へと敵が出てくるんです
だから自分の能力次第なんですよ
コンピューターはいくらでももう敵を作るんです
終わりがないんです 機械ですから
相手が そこでこちらが素早く鋭く考えながら
うまくゲームをすればいいんです
だからそちらの色々決まりがあって
その決まりを守ってうまくゲームをすればいいんで
とにかく抱かれてかすっていうことは大体ないんですからね
コンピューターゲームの場合は
もう何点取ったかということで終わっちゃうんです
だから人生も同じことで
いくら注意深く通ったっても
あの自然災害もあるし
そんなもん乗り越えられませんし
病気にもなるし 歳も取るし
好きな人々がもうどんどん死んでしまっちゃうし
あるいは離れていっちゃうし
そういうのも毎日あることだから
やがて自分ももう生ゴミ扱いされちゃって死んでしまっちゃうし
そこはごく普通なことですから
コンピューターゲームだよと
いくら鋭くチャレンジしたっても
最後にゲームオーバーということは出てくるんです
そこでゲームオーバーになって悔しいんだからと言って誰かにぶつかるんですかね
このゲーム作った会社に電話かけて文句言うんですかね
誰もそういうことしませんだけど
あんた方のゲームは良くないんだと
私は負けましたと だったらあんたがアホやと言うだけの答えになりますよ
だから文句言う必要ないんです
ゲーム論の場合は そこでテニスとかね
野球とか そういう この
それはもうちょっとした遊びでしょうに
まあそんなことでもうじゃあ負けるためにやる人がいませんだから
負けるためだったらこれゲームにならないでしょうに
そういう場合も私が言うのは自分の力出せと
自分の力全部出したところで
負けたって決して悔しくはないでしょうに
面白いスポーツやりたければ
相手が強いほど面白いでしょうに
自分がメダル取りたいんだからね
相手がすごく弱くなってほしいと
神様に罰が当たってほしいと
あるいはどこかに行って何か呪いかけたりしたら
それはゲームじゃないでしょうに
だから そういう本当に戦わなくてはならない時でも
相手が強ければ強いほど
自分がそれにどんな風に対応すればいいかと
自分の力思い存分出すことによっていい試合は成り立つんです
それで十分なんです どうしても勝てなくてはならないという考え方は非論理的な
もういい加減な話なんです
そんなことはないんだから
勝っても負けてもどっちでもいいんだけど
そういう競争的なゲームのスポーツの場合は
必要なことは正々堂々とそれをやることなんですね
それで面白いし それこそ道であろうしね
まあ大体ゲームの場合はまあそれぐらいにいたしますけど
そこで最終的には一つ文句も通してこの覚えておいてほしいことがあるんです
この世の中で生きるために
それはパーリ語で書きます
これアッターナンチェピアジャンニャ
ラッケイアナンスラッキタン
アッターナンチェピアジャンニャ
ラッケイアナンスラッキタンという言葉
意味はアッターナンチェピアジャンニャ
アッターナンというのは自分のこと
ピアンというのは好きということで
ジャンニャ そういう風に思うならば
自分のことを好きだと思うならば
ラッケイアナン 自分のナンというのは自分のことをラッケイヤ
守りなさいと スラッキタン
とてもとてもよく守りなさいと
その言葉を日本語でもいいんですけど
覚えておいてほしいんです
ポイント 2つあります
自分のことを好きになること
自分のことを嫌だと思うのは
これ精神的な病気なんです
まず自分のことを好きになること
自分のこと好きだったら自分を守れと
この自分を守る方法を考えれば
行く道を見つかるんです
自分を守る方向へ行くと
大体全部うまくいくんですね
だから どのように守ればいいかわからない人々にお釈迦様はいろいろ教えているんです
一つ言えばこういうこと
どう考えたっても悪いことだ
悪いことにはどんな責められたっても手を出すな
間違ってでも あるいは脅されてでも悪いことだけはやめろと
なぜかというと その時はやるんだけど
後で悪い結果になるでしょうに
たとえ会社の社長に言われたっても
法律的でないことをやりなさいと言ったら
自分が社員の身分かもしれません
でも社長に社長 これは法律的には間違ってますよと
これやったらこれやったのは私になりますから
バレたところで私は大変な目に遭いますよ
やめます だからやりませんと
そうやって自分を守ればいいのです
その時はもうダメと言った方がいいのです
たとえ会社の社長であろうとも
もう誰でもいいのです
やりません 間違ってるんだから
その時 なんでやりませんと
これ頑固ではなくて 自分を守るんです
今 世界ではバレなきゃいいんだと
そんなもう人間の生き方じゃないんです
これで誰かが辞任するとかね
もしバレなかったら辞任することでもなくもなく
いい加減なことをやるでしょうに
だから警察官がもうもう痴漢して見つかる
捕まるんだと まあ大したことないんだけど
でも自分を守ってないでしょうに
酔っていたんだからそんな言い訳言ったっても恥もいいところでしょうに
犯罪を捕まえる立場にいて
自分で犯罪をする だからそういう警察官の人でも
大胆にもう理想的な警察官になってなってやるぞって
そんなことはもう別の人間だからできないかもしれませんだけど
一応自分だけ守っておけば
警察官が痴漢して捕まったりしたり
その家族の立場から全てもう次から次へと壊れるでしょうし
特に日本では 日本というのはものすごいものすごい違う世界だから
人が間違ってでも間違い事を起こしちゃったら
みんな戦利になってその人を責める
なんかもう天使たちの集まりみたいんですよ
みんな何一つ悪いことしないような感じで
誰かが悪いことしちゃったら
その家族であろうか 親戚であろうがみんな責める
だから生きづらいんですよ
息子が何か犯罪を起こしたんだからと
隣の奥さんがそのお母さんを慰めなければいけないでしょうに
そうはしません あの家で犯罪
初陣を起こしちゃったよとか
それも人間らしい生き方ではないんだけど
だから自分のことを自分で守らなくてはいけないんです
この世の中恐ろしいんです
慈悲はないんです 人っていうのはもうしょっちゅう間違いを起こしますよとは
それ理解できない人間に
自分がものすごい間違いを犯しているのに
あんた間違いを犯したんではあんた間違いした
他人にばっかり指をさす
できてない人々なんですよ
能力もないし 理解もできませんし
だからまあ 人間のことをね
なんか全部脳細胞を取って
生まれる前に取っておいたような感じの生き物だから
仏教の人々はまあだから気をつけましょうと
自分を守りましょうと
だから この慈しみない社会について
嫉妬する 憎しみ 怒り 競争
相手を倒す それしか考えていないこの世の中で
仏教徒が自分を守る それで相手を倒すことなく
自分が光り輝いて生きていられるんです
ですから お釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
自分を守りなさいと そういうことで
このいろんなことを教えていますよ
例えば あるところでこう教えるんです
カハパンワッセンティッティカーメスウィッジャティ
あの小判小判というんですか
小判ですね 金 小判が雨のように降ってきたっても
人間の欲にはキリがないんだと
満足しませんと だから
金儲かります 儲かりますと言っちゃったら
自分を守れません なぜかというと
いくらあっても足らないんだから
ですから そのことわざを覚えて
小判の雨が降っても 人には足りることはありませんと
ゆえに自分が小欲 何でしたっけ
知足で生きているんだ
その方が自分を守られるんだと
儲かるんだと思って もう財産全部投げ捨てたところで
もう何もなくなる可能性はあります
そういうことだから いつでも自分を守れということをやっていただきたいんですね
それからまたあるところでネタンカンマンカタンサードゥヤンカットアヌタッパティ
後でやらなかった方がよかったなと後悔することはやらない方が最初からやらない方がいいと
たとえ小さくても後悔するべきものはやらないと覚悟を決めて
鬼門に命じてというんですか
覚えておく 恥になること
後悔すること 恥ずかしくなること
たとえ小さくたってもダメとやりませんと
なぜかというと そんなことをやっちゃったら
後でもうやらなかった方がよかったと悩むだけ
何も答えがないでしょうに
時々は政治家の世界で
そういう昔一回いろいろケース出たでしょうに
総理大臣とか何とかになったら
あんたこういうこういう風な商売やったんではないかとか
それは悪いんではないかとかね
後でバレたりして それで辞任したりするでしょうし
だから生まれた時からもう悪いことに手を染めなかったならば問題ないでしょ
総理大臣やら何々大臣とかになったら
どうせみんな批判する
いろんなところを調べる
いくら調べたっても 欠陥は見つからない人格だったらすごいでしょうに
ですから お釈迦様は言うのは
後で悩むことになるものは
最初からも考えてやめなさいと
その自信 その強さは必要です
頑固さではなくて それでこの競争についてお釈迦様はこういう言葉を言っているんです
パラドックスウーパダーネーナアッタノースカミッチャティウェーラサンガサンサッガサンサットーウェーラソーナパリムッチャティというお釈迦様の言葉で
他人に迷惑をかけて自分が幸せになると思ったならば
その人はいつでも怒りで燃えているんだから
一向に幸せになりませんと
ということは 競争する人
他人を潰そうと思う人が一向に幸せにならないと
なぜかと 自分の心の中で怒り
憎しみ 競争心でずっと燃えているんだから
何の幸せも安らぎもないんですよ
怒り憎しみっていうのは
才能っていうのは壊すんです
潰すんです 心の安らぎ
落ち着きは才能が開発してくれるんです
たとえ歌える人であろうとも
緊張しちゃうと歌えなくなっちゃう
どんな人でもすごく怒りも嫉妬
憎しみも いろんなことでも心が揺れていると何もできなくなるんです
持っているものも出せなくなっちゃうんです
ですから いつでもリラックス状態で心を守ってほしい
そういうことだから 他人に迷惑をかけて
他人をいじめて自分が幸せになると思ったら
それは勘違いですよと
自分が怒りで燃えているんだから
損するのは自分ですよと
そのような生き方で 我々にはこの何て言いますか
勝者として生きていられる
でも敗者は誰もいませんと
生き方は成り立つんです
敗者のところがみんなに助けてもらう
みんなは幸せになる 自分が勝者になったことによって
全ての人々は幸せになるんだと
そういう道を選ぶということなんですね
だからお祈りするんでもなくて
希望ばっかしするんでもなくて
着々と客観的に論理的に生きてみなさいと
そうすると人間には知恵が出てきますし
知恵を使わなくてはならなくなっちゃうし
だからとにかく仏教っていうのはwisdomの教えということだから
知恵の教えだからね そこを開発してくると
もう いかなる問題でも解決できて
一切の苦しみをなくすことまでは成長することはできるんです
ということで じゃあ頑張ってみてください
どうもありがとうございました